the hilarious jennifer coolidge stopped
by the tonight show jimmy fallon where
she reacted to ariana grande's spot on
impression of her and credited both
ariana and jimmy for giving her a career
boost take a look at this we'll see you
back here next week have a great
weekend oh my god but the first time i
think i heard anyone do an impression of
you is when ariana grande was here a few
years ago
and here's ariana's impression of
jennifer
god
you look like the fourth of july
taking the dog dumbass
[Applause]
come on
ariana grande crushing that it's a great
impression oh unbelievable but you know
um you should know that it was sort of
the beginning of a lot of cool things
that happened for me because um i don't
know i sort of you know
i was going through a dead zone and um
you know certain not much was going on
and then
ariana did this imitation on your show
and um you encouraged her and um and
then
this ball got rolling i mean
you know um
my friend who's like her age teresa she
was like hey you know you should dm
ariana
and just say you know you know because i
thought it was such a good invitation
and i was like
no she's got like 260 million followers
those are robots the robots answer the
dms
and we will never ever get to whatever
and then
we i did it anyway and then this
response came back and then
the next thing you know i was like going
to her house getting fit for a
wardrobe fitting for for thank you next
that was all because of jimmy fallon and
you know